well I think the fascinating thing is
slavery slavery was the order of the day
and the leading philosophers and moral
thinkers of our time from Jesus to the
Buddha to Mohammed to Socrates and
Aristotle to all of them never ever
really spoke much about slavery about
owning other human beings about selling
someone's children they just was never
really brought up I mean it just wasn't
you just see it's like it was just what
was done and then you know really
started the abolitionist movement that
they were they I mean the the beginnings
of the abolition of slavery worldwide
you know did it no British in the
eighteen hundreds really a button you
know did it in specifically evangelical
Christians the abolition movement was
started by what you'd call you know
fanatic you know Christians but they
were they were they were they risked
everything and convinced the crown to
enforce a ban on slavery in the high
seas so if you were a British naval you
know ship even if the Ottoman if there
was a Turkish ship of the Ottoman ship
over there and they had slaves the
British were spent years and great cost
at basically hanging slave traders
freeing slaves all that stuff on the
high seas yes you know even though there
obviously there was a lot of racism that
went on the Brits and their Navy were
the ones that began the abolition of
worldwide slavery didn't allow it on the
high seas now how amazing is it that
that didn't take place into what 18 1865
sir
now listen well that's when it was
abolished in America it was that
abolished the all country no a Britain
abolish slavery I believe wearily er
than America so we were 1865 or 1869
when another thing to remember is the
United States has been a country with
slavery longer that's been a country
without so that gives you an idea have a
recent that is okay just stop and think
about that yeah that number 1865 seems
so recent now used to when I was a kid
it felt like it was forever again I know
when I was like five years old
I thought about slavery I thought about
it as being like eons and eons in the
past
do you know a book I just read it and
it's it's the it is without besides the
Bible a lot of arguably one of the most
influential books ever in the written in
the 19th century what yeah Uncle Tom's
Cabin whoa yeah I realized I hadn't read
it and well I mean I think that the
Ariat Beecher Stowe and and I think the
legend is that Lincoln said so you're
the little woman that wrote this book
that started this great war because she
she put this she had never actually she
was from the north but she interviewed
fugitive slaves and people who you know
we used to be and if you read that book
man it was it puts such a face on what
slavery the brutality what it was really
about in this country or anywhere where
you could take a woman's child an
eight-year-old and you get some money
and it's the story where the slave
trader goes well I'll buy the kiddies
yeah I could fetch a good price for him
down south and well we'll take him when
his mom ain't there maybe gave it go do
a chore so when she comes back you know
otherwise it's all kinds of hemming and
hawing and they had slave brokers who
wouldn't come in and go look your
plantation is in debt you got to start
selling some of your slaves now I'm not
gonna take those guys but that that
woman she's got she's got those two
healthy-looking boys and they and you
would sell them and she could do nothing
about it that was the reality and and
Uncle Tom's Cabin controversial book
because the way they described Uncle Tom
as a simpleton and a negro but I'll tell
you what it did is she she made you
realize in Technicolor
with a human face just exactly how
horrible it was and what happened to the
women who would have to see their
children sold in front of them and they
couldn't do anything blah blah blah but
but yeah that's on the blahblah it was
well it was it was for many people what
galvanized the North to say we can't
have so this is crazy
can't have slavery